so we have this story from the
independent
i chose the independent on purpose for
the source of this story
saki links kyle right now to proud boys
after teenager hits out at biden over
white supremacist defamation secretary
notes written as his photo with right
wing group excluded from trial ah
interesting uh the reason i chose the
independent is because this is the
outlet that claimed kyle rittenhouse
shot three black people i noticed that
which is not true
so of all of the outlets that would like
to make a comment on kyle rittenhouse
and defamation i thought this would be
the funniest one to use
the evidence says that peter ducey asked
whether or not mr biden would ever
apologize to mr rittenhouse for
suggesting online and on tv that he's a
white supremacist and saki responded the
video was meant to show how trump
actively encouraged white supremacists
and right-wing militia groups during his
presidency in her answer she referred to
a 2020 photo that showed written house
posing with a member of the proud boys
biden mr biden she added spoke to the
verdict last week he has obviously
condemned the hatred and division and
violence we've seen around the country
committed by groups like the proud boys
and groups that individual has posed in
photos with ducey's question did not
address the photo referenced by seki
blah blah blah i love it i love it i
love this idea that uh how many how many
conflicts are the proud boys involved in
you know a decent amount but have the
proud boys ever gone out actively
destroying neighborhoods setting fires
firebombing buildings or anything like
that um i oh wait wait wait
enrique tario pulled down a banner that
said black lives matter and they burned
in a street yep so that was that a
multi-racial uh person yeah by the way
and the organization is not a white
supremacist organization there's many
people of color within it and again it's
just absurd the logic that they're using
here okay let's use the same logic joe
biden took a picture with putin biden is
the president of russia now come on
that's ridiculous
he's a russian advocate exactly and and
kyle's words against the president
yesterday on that tucker carlson
interview were very pointed and i think
he's preparing for something bigger here
because he said he's accusing the
president of using malice and defamation
as you mentioned before actual malice
that's a legal phrase yeah exactly
saying someone has malice you know in a
public setting like if you were like he
was maliciously smearing me or that
smear was you know his malice i mean
that just basically means like they're
mad at you they don't like you actual
malice is the legal is is the standard
is the legal standard by which you can
sue a public figure so here's what i
think happened i think ritas was talking
to his lawyers
and he and and they said you know we
believe what biden said about you is
actual malice or maybe something that
effect and then kyle was like oh yeah in
the colloquial sense and then says it to
tucker
but it sounds like he's being you know
he's having these discussions now truth
be told you can call someone a white
supremacist and it is not defamation
it's not it's an opinion is is it okay
to give
sake a compliment okay because of course
yeah because
after four years in the white house i
gotta hand it to her she lies she's
pretty much better than anybody we had
and i proposed um uh
the gensake drinking game by the way
which was every time she lied uh you'd
have to take a drink a shot of sake
right you see
perfect
you know it'd be a short party because
everybody be passed out on the floor
within 30 minutes of the press
conference but it's really i mean the
the thing that strikes me
is that
um again you asked me kind of
perspective from from from my age and
things like that it's we we've we've
abandoned all notion of any kind of
truth and now it's just simply a battle
of spin and narratives i mean it's like
you go you wake up in the morning
and the the the cnn and mbas nbc people
are just
lazy they let the spin and narrative
come out of the new york times in the
washington post or whatever bullet
points the political cannons might be
sent in and then off they run with it
and then you know we've got folks on the
other side of that but i mean it's just
just well
nbc
they're they're a lot worse than that so
during the trial and this nbc journalist
was trying to get photographs this is
the jury i mean this is another po yeah
it's like crazy like can you imagine
that like following an msnbc
reporter following a juror
to their home
you'll never see morning joe wax
eloquently
okay well it's like lebron like these
people are so hypocritical like
lebron james on china right i mean look
it's like lebron james will be the first
one to just just trash this country
upside the head i mean it's oh this is a
terrible place to live right but but
then you've got two million people in
concentration camps
in china and it's like can't talk about
that no no i can't nope
did some basketball player wear like
[ __ ] or something yes there was a boston
celtics player that wore a shoe
depicting lebron bending over
of course china bowing down
to uh winnie the pooh yeah uh as he was
playing against lebron james yeah he's
also suspended for sucker punching uh
another player my hero my hero in the
nba is uh enis canner right that's him
yeah because and and so he's protesting
now and guess what he's sitting on the
bench rather than playing you know this
this is not you know this is not cool
yeah there's another there's another nba
star when colin kaepernick protested and
he eventually gets booed and nobody
wants to have him around i'm like you
get political you get into it you know
yeah yeah and they should i think we
should have these debates i think we we
shouldn't be afraid of politicizing
things kwame brown another former nba
star came out and he said surprisingly
kyle wright house acted in quote
self-defense he goes on to say that the
case was politicized for people to make
a lot of money promoting racism at the
expense of a teenager and a lot of
people were resonating with those points
after of course watching the trial that
was a live stream and presented a
different point of view that people were
denied if of course they were watching
the corporate media which many of them
didn't even put on the arguments that
the defense was even making during this
entire case which is crazy you know
what's crazy uh so the episode i
recorded a show with joe rogan last week
it went up yesterday and i was uh
reading some comments
and people were saying like you know i'm
watching this for i'm listening for 45
minutes and i swear this guy's just
making all this stuff up
it's because they live in the world of
cnn right and msnbc so when i sit there
and say something like cal rittenhouse
didn't cross state lines of the gun in
fact the d.a binger has charged dominic
black under the same statute because of
the straw purchase and i don't think
it's a straw purchase charge but they're
basically saying you provided a weapon
to a miner and then these people listen
to that and they're like that's not true
joy reid told me he colbert said he
crossed state lines i watch colbert he's
lying isn't he and i keep saying fact
check me google this take five seconds
just figure out we are telling you the
truth this is this is the important
thing i want to say about the cal right
now stuff
i hope everybody remembers when it came
to this show when it came to my my
morning show the the seven witnesses we
had we told you from the beginning it
was self-defense everything that came
out in the trial maybe maybe you're
someone who only realized by watching
the trial what was going on
watch our show you'll see we were never
lying to you we had the witnesses here
tell their stories some of these same
people have been on this show went on to
testify for the state and the defense in
that trial and sure enough the jury said
not guilty on all counts we had will
chamberlain here who said the gun
possession was legal the charge is bunk
guess what the judge said actually
that's correct now if you were watching
cnn the whole time you got punked
we were honest with you the whole time
let me say one thing about cnn too
because um
john berman new day i
just happened to hear
the show in the morning
uh talking about the case tim and what
what just sickened me was the tone in
his voice
signaling that he wanted this 17 year
old person
convicted that was he was reporting the
quote news which was wrong and
contradictory to everything you just
said
but at the same time you could feel in
his the way he was reporting it was like
oh we we've got to get this guy
convicted i mean what what a 17 year old
kid
who
was was not guilty and found not guilty
by
by his peers
he's being condemned to
life imprisonment by the tone of that
voice
those people who listen to cnn
that they they buy into that you see
colbert colbert said if that's not
against the law we should change the law
what they're really saying is for for
the past decade they have escalated
their violence and their riots and
they've gotten away with it and at this
point well now people are starting to
snap and i don't think it's a good thing
people showing up and you know
what happened in kenosha i don't think
is good in any way
but people are finally fed up we've seen
videos of people getting into fist
fights with antifa chasing them out well
now what's happening is these leftist
extremists are shocked and angry that oh
no now we're dealing with resistance
from people who don't want us burning
down their local communities now the
courts have said if you attack someone
and threaten great bodily harm we are
there's no precedent there's always been
self-defense well that offends the likes
of colbert no colbert
when when they were burning down
buildings when they were fire bombing
you know government facilities when
small towns were getting looted and
ransacked where where was colby
the word kamala harris was fundraising
for these people to bail him out so when
this ruling comes in they say the judge
is biased snl does a skit about it and
they say there's white supremacy blah
blah blah they're just angry that
regular people have had enough of their
extremism it's a battle of narratives
that's what that's what we've become in
this
uh
society the the media has has gone into
the the traditional media has gone into
their respective corners and it's a
battle of opinion-driven
narratives not fact-based narratives and
i i'm
listening to you that actually you
actually had the witnesses on that blows
my mind that's a beautiful thing it's a
beautiful thing yeah you know what i
realized today
when i was reading you know people are
commenting on rogan's podcast there's
actually two different political
compasses so when we say like you know
luke is like right libertarian or
whatever how people describe it and i'm
like left-leaning libertarian and i
don't know where ian is he's in outer
space yeah pretty much
libertarian pro well probably but you're
probably more authoritarian than i am
thanks for checking out this segment
from the tim cast irl podcast if you
want to watch live you can check out
this channel monday through friday at 8
00 pm and don't forget to smash that
like button subscribe to this channel
and if you want more unfiltered and
uncensored content with all of these
guests go to timcast.com and become a
member all of these guests you know and
love in exclusive segments on our
website where we are unrestricted in
what we talk about so you'll definitely
not want to miss it thanks for hanging
out we'll see you all next time